the 20 day limit on holding children
even with their parents was established
in a 1997 government agreement once that
time is up they have to be released or
moved elsewhere Paula Reed is at the
White House was more on the executive
order that will keep families in custody
together at least for now Paula good
morning good morning Gail now the
administration will continue to
prosecute every adult who illegally
crosses the border a big change now
though is that children can remain with
their parents while those adults await
prosecution but the president's
executive order does not override
something called the Flores settlement
and that requires that children cannot
be detained in any government facility
for more than 20 days so in less than
three weeks the government may still
have to once again separate families now
Attorney General Jeff Sessions he is
expected to ask a federal judge in
California to modify the Flores
Agreement so that families can remain
together while being detained but it's
unclear how long it'll take to litigate
this issue or whether the judge would be
willing to permit the indefinite
detention of minors so without a
modification of the Flores agreement
Congress has less than three weeks to
come up with a permanent solution there
that will be two votes today on two
separate there will be votes today on
two separate proposals one is a
hard-line proposal from Republicans the
other is more of a compromise bill it's
unclear whether or not either has enough
votes to pass but the president said
that he would support either proposal
John Paula thank you